la majorité des produits qui sont à
l'intérieur c'est des produits qui nous
ont demandé au niveau de l'école ce père
vient de compléter ses achats pour la
rentrée scolaire de son fils d'habitude
on paye maximum 160 pièces pour l'année
mais comme aujourd'hui j'étais étonné ma
fête une facture à 341 dollars pour la
un élève de primaire de 4e année moi
j'ai arrivé à payer ça nous as
spontanément fait part de ses
impressions sur sa facture c'est
vraiment catastrophe pour les classes
pauvres je vous ai même pas poser de
questions moi j'ai répondu à toutes les
questions
il a fait ses emplettes dans cette
papeterie de Montréal tenue par une
ancienne ingénieure qui a changé de
vocation par passion
elle constate que le coup de certains
produits à Bondy comparativement à l'an
dernier si on regarde un sac à dos par
exemple
juste pour un exemple regardez l'année
passée je l'ai vendais à comment 39 41
plus tard cette année sont rendus à 49
estime qu'en moyenne l'augmentation des
prix des effets scolaires et d'environ
15% cette année mais Rihanna des items
qui sont même à 30% oui je sais mon
oiseau pour faire face à la hausse
option consommateur suggère la
préparation du fameux budget et aussi de
récupérer ce qui peut l'être évidemment
on commence par faire l'inventaire des
matériaux qu'on a déjà qui sont
récupérables de la nuit précédente faut
pas hésiter aussi à faire des échanges
peut-être avec des familles amis qui qui
ont certains effets dont ils ont plus
moins en fait ce que j'ai fait c'est
vous allez voir dans ce que les enfants
avaient déjà donc on le fait encore plus
cette année on a pas le choix c'est
c'est une dépense qui est nécessaire
alors on fait avec ce qui est comme ce
sont surtout les familles à faible
revenu il y a le 2 1 qui est une
ressource pour vous aider à trouver des
ressources selon le quartier ou la ville
où vous habitez parfait merci si Mélissa
François Radio-Canada Montréal